instead of jockeying and politicking and
pondering and posturing and debating for
three to four months we're just a duo
now and when you're in do mode you
[ __ ] get [ __ ] done waiting seems to
be
episode 9 of dailyvee was just posted
and episode 10 is an action it's so
wrong and influence for marketing I
think most people are undereducated and
would go the route of impressions and so
I think they would go to a DJ Khaled or
somebody that looked like me you know
and say how many views are you getting
on your story and then they would apply
a CPM against that and that would be
that and that would be that would be a
grave mistake of not understanding the
difference of values of an a Twitter
impression versus a snapchat impression
versus of Instagram impression what gets
me excited about snapchat and why I'm
excited about is I think people are
actually consuming those impressions
when I have twenty five twenty five
thousand views on my on my stories on
snapchat I no question believe that it
is more valuable than the two hundred
twenty five thousand followers I have an
Instagram that potentially see it right
or Twitter or Facebook so so I gain
trade attention right that's what I do
for a living I reverse-engineer
attention my belief is that snapchat is
snapchat an Instagram right now with the
two kings and queens of attention
we go straight gonna make a left go
straight we're making a left into this
big building right here
dear friend
it's available
Thanks let me know what my options are
thanks
girl I'm gonna come back I believe I
just had 30 minutes to kill and better
go kill with you guys then hey guys hi
how are you good to see you
awesome hey how are you I think we
should really have signs on the bottom
of the front doors when we walk in
consistently I think we have like the
Great Wall there for a while I think you
should pick two prot like I think
there's hey Willy I don't think there's
a single better spot I think you would
sell a lot more wine from the that spot
than the pillars okay I think you should
consistently sign that are you good man
how are you
yeah once something sells out of limits
from the site yep do you think that was
why was it love well I was that buddy -
what was that buddy to you that I like
say something about Wine Library hello
how are you good to see you
are you so good - good to see you too
I'll get she has family younger I know
I'm getting you know I'm taking care of
my health
it helps thanks a lot how are you good
are you doing really good what's cooking
not much help yourself we're dia he's
coming back soon he's back today right
actually Lance today okay I just love
talking operations wine library
operations it's kind of like riding a
bike you know since my family business
it's kind of like a first love it's kind
of like you know that meeting with Mitch
talking about where we're going and how
we want to strategize from a financial
standpoint for the business is kind of
like having coffee with your your
highschool sweetheart when you're in
your 40s or 50s it's been a long time
and you're you're out of touch and you
don't have all the contacts but there's
still that feeling and and clearly when
I get into that mindset it's really just
like riding a bike it's just I'm right
back in it even though at this point my
dad and Brandon they're running the
business it's not hard for me to
calibrate and an attack the business
situation at hand are you sick Eric
she's [ __ ] all right listen honestly
like like because we had a pre talk for
like five seconds and everybody here is
wicked smart and sharp and fast as [ __ ]
is there anything that at what what do I
need to know so I can get you back to
rest yep yep I didn't focus on YouTube
for almost all my career into this
character got along and so like
literally YouTube's been a focus of mine
for a year now 18 months
what uh what was our following Cal we
started like we did that the other day
like 30,000 35,000 now we're at a buck
25 115 let me think about that you know
eight years to get the 35 and one year
to get a hundred thousand more 144 love
it it's going fast one of the biggest
secrets and business is when you have
clients to remind yourself that they're
the customer and they're right you could
fire them but while you have them there
right yes he is
you're there good we gotta get d-roc no
race it's unbelievable how much I hate
the Patriots yeah I really don't like
that was pretty good as the Broncos held
it look like it would do they're gonna
float again oh the respect level I have
for the Patriots those insane like it
I'm always like they're gonna win I
don't have to we're gonna do here that
you know I'd finally articulated what I
do for a living and I'll and I can
deploy it now here but for some of the
meetings instead of the interviewer it
popped up I didn't trade attention
mm-hmm I day trade attention cuz it's
not it's not like we painters market in
the year that you live in and I keep
like looking at it for the last six
months and like [ __ ] we don't like we're
doing it faster than that yeah it's not
year we don't make a 2016 plan like I
decided on December 23rd at snapchat
became very important and then like it
just it like it's day trading somebody
so here's where I'm about to go so I
fully agree with that let me throw you
one that I think is very winnable and
can be completely game-changing what
about a monthly for the brand starting
right away
meaning I'm standing which means you
know Dirac uh so I think you're so
[ __ ] right and that when I think
about and I do think it needs a website
but when I debate I thought yeah as I
Jamie says especially especially but I'd
rather if I had my way if you save all
I'd rather save a hundred thousand
dollars or fifty thousand dollars more
on the website whatever that meant
you know depth creative whatever meant
literally literally literally and it's
like how PR works right it's how I its
what I'm doing here with the rock I'm
not going to ask I when I'm asked to be
on in Inc or in business insider or in
like Fast Company you're asking
now I produce content I posted they're
asking me to distribute it on their
Channel
I tell you why this is genius thank you
it's not your son with that well on
digital how do i how do I get it
and get me the four one one now I'll
follow up and be the bad cop yeah all
right I bought one from there yeah yeah
we have the best prices I'm dead of your
eyes I'm aware it's the best prices best
prices you have to come off more often
yeah at the tools yeah
hello my friend
good man sorry to hear about your dad
how you doing
keep me up keep me updated if anything
goat yeah keep me updated if anything
gets bad hope of course I've caught this
there's nothing and don't worry we'll
we'll do more I want to actually give
you a preview so you know what you're
walking into today so
thank you a pleasure thank you have a
great day
I said for you
hey sir - see ya - see ya sir he has
everything everything super well guys
good to see you guys
I find them hiding good to see you good
to see you sir hey how are you really
well brother how are you alright let's
do this so I think uh I think for
everybody on the call I think this is
grounded in growing the revenue of this
company this company obviously has
different uniqueness because it's bricks
and mortar and retail different than a
pure play econ play and number two is
any outstandingly regulated industry and
we're like any other company that we
deal with we have a lot of our own
legacies uh you know John Kay when did
we start working together 1999 when you
were at Red Hat or what it was called
yeah so John and I have basically been
working on winelibrary.com since 1998
brands been here since that time frame
299 what have you and so we have a ton
of legacy stuff we uh and there's a lot
that needs to be done and we're seeing
it already even with little old two
seconds into affiliate marketing which
is by the way from everything I've
gathered of the 50 million dollar
revenue that wine.com does more than
half comes from affiliate sales right so
like so there's so much we can do here
we have the one thing down which is we
have multiple things down we have one
core thing down we actually have one of
the five or seven best wine shops in
America like from a selection and price
standpoint we actually have that that's
exciting number two we have Brian Willie
who actually should probably go around
introduce ourselves Brian and John who's
on the phone
who are long tenured real family of this
company developers were in-house who
after we decide what we do here we'll
add on or not add on whatever you know
are just capable of bringing so much
more to the table because they care more
and they're capable so we have all the
pieces in place to do great stuff
I think it's just time to do it I'm
gonna go countercultural and go
old-school phone sales and email and
texting out of one so I'm gonna want on
I'm gonna want Thank You economy the
whole business I'm gonna go one-on-one
on every individual person that's ever
bought anything in this company ever so
that's where I want all the energy to go
so like all the 4% margin that you bring
me on affiliate or nine or six or twelve
every one of those dollars is going to
go into wreck at seventy thousand
dollars a year with all my investment on
these guys to build unbelievable admin
tools that make them the best human
salespeople so instead of these guys
worrying about moving their to correct
moving [ __ ] data and and by the way
the thing that they don't worry about
that's really on my head the company's
not worried about at all which is best
practices calm like landing page and
like and like [ __ ] affiliate like we
fix all that all that can go into
something that I know that I uniquely
can do in the industry that most people
can't which is build back-end data tools
that make people settle online now that
we have the man and women power of
vaynermedia to help this I would never
ask John or Brandon to do this because
I'm the most practical operator of all
time not to ask my people to do things
they can't do or are not as the high use
of their time I think it would be super
fascinating to understand the
inefficiency of all the hours that go
back and forth from these missing items
versus the big on my FedEx shipping
charges to see if like because if we
just start shipping this and not going
back and forth communicating on all
these admins and customers are getting
four bottles and then they come later
there's a big there's a big financial
loss we don't pay the people that
actually have to play with this a whole
lot like in comparison to what I think
but the more you know has I come in with
fresh eyes I'm curious to see what the
Vegas for example if you said it was a
net loss of thirty five thousand dollars
a year I would do that for customers
just getting product way faster so I
need the math goddam John you understood
that rant right like we're gonna try to
figure that out there and by the way
when I say we that just means that you
and Brandon Brian and Brian dela Torre
just have to be communicating to Pam
when she asks the question because
whether it's Pam or somebody else
they'll be coming in here to like try to
collect enough data to make
have to look at the numbers to see yeah
make sense huh what I'm doing right now
is one reeducate myself two clearly
putting [ __ ] in your guys heads so that
you guys know what I don't need to be I
don't wanna be in the next 17 meetings I
want you guys to take over so and when I
say you guys I mean the collective team
here like there's [ __ ] 50 years of IP
in these guys heads that have to be
regurgitated their disadvantage is my
disadvantage which is their accepting
everything that has been for the last 10
years so that's like let's take it like
every time we dealt with stuff you know
one bottle we would take it off the site
we've never debated partial ship because
I die not that created certain rules for
life that being one of them that's where
you guys have an advantage over them
that collective friction is what needs
to come out of this so this conversation
was around like operationally how how do
we handle this stuff so we do want to
talk about the marketing side of it the
marketing calendar the things you said
that while we control it drag me we put
the email out and stuff like that I need
to understand that a little bit better
about dirt Oh
today everything how does that process
work
is there a marketing calendar do you
work on a month I had to say that is
what we will be promoting or it might be
an inventory issue and you're trying to
get rid of and turn it into cash yes oh
all of those things yes all of us for
Brandon yeah and what you dancers yes
email is the backbone of this business
okay we massively like one of the things
that I think we've did so a couple years
ago I poked my head in three or four
years ago knows like [ __ ] our email
promotions are not as strong so I
leveled up an email promotions called a
takeover you'd go to Wine Library on
then I would [ __ ] the [ __ ] I complain
about you know take over the whole site
and it would lead up to this big event
and we would sell a lot and then 18
months ago or so or 12 months ago I was
like let's do one of those every week
every week there'd be one big item and
it did well and it still does well and
it's still the big thing when we went to
the redesign we never did or take over
like a full like now it's just like a
story on our website so I'm excited to
see how Shopify's UI up front
works because the thought of like
promoting to the big wine offering a
week in advance is very powerful we
would plant very aggressively for that
even eight to twelve weeks out because
they'd be very high margin items a lot
of what Brandon would decide would be 24
hours in advance based on the
inventories and based on his buying so
the promotion the brochure calendar
would at best be a week ahead of time
at worst the morning of but Wow and a
good and it depends on how you want to
look at that one so for me as an
outsider now I'm I like it because it's
day trading like we're making the
smartest decision what he's definitely
capable of when he doesn't overthink it
is is making the best decision for that
day different types of affiliates eight
to ten different types of affiliates
right so there are certain types you
have to keep on feeding them what they
love it when when you are giving them
these kind of I'll call them flash sales
right you're making the decision that
day just taking a rock hard and our
ability to reverse it like this is the
first time hearing this like our ability
to feed everybody from RetailMeNot two
whiny wine wine that you tell us who the
eight are and what they need to be the
best is a piece of cake our ability to
feed them fifty-two offers is much
higher than you could ever imagine
because that's something we've got down
we just have to know what the rules are
I mean hire somebody to create more
infrastructure but that's not hard this
is where being like a great wine store
is gonna really help like if it needs to
be a product specific like was seventy
now twenty for me tell me not only
people we can [ __ ] feed that animal
whole day okay uh yeah I mean I assume
that's what you're referring to this the
way I think about affiliate is 20% off
any order five you know five buy one get
one free but if you're talking about
feeding like that's just literally level
one so god bless tell me I'll give you
level nine that part I can [ __ ] we can
crush I really want to build something
look I want your loyalty and all these
great years like my big thing right now
is for five or six of you like it's
driving me more than anything for five
or six of you to have the hyper
growth that you felt underneath me from
being a kid that sat on a safe to being
like right I want to replicate that for
the five or six of you over the next
three to five years like you and I what
we just did for five minutes is better
for business like that and that's what
I'm good for so what I want to do is an
hour a day instead of ops which is
important you auditing your order
department or your pullers operations
well Brandon needs help there I want you
to become that guy for him let's find
people that can become the next you and
Jeff and yeah as in Kevin you don't need
and there we go
so how about it I mean okay that's here
good stuff right good talk right
177 177 right
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is a book 177 of the ass gallon
game show
snapchat wine library the legit wine
palace of the world who's that
good-looking guy holy crap that dude is
amazing you are handsome how are you are
you good man how are you good battle
care like like meaning like the answer
is that's the right question and we
should talk to them um but it's not
rocket britain first of all like we've
been doing this a long time it's not
only oh that's the stupidest [ __ ] I've
ever heard in my life
like we're [ __ ] good that's why I'm
not scared if we were [ __ ] I'd want to
stage everything
as everybody is that is everybody trying
to keep up with the with the energy here
have a little fun okay thank you
is
so today was a really interesting day
really got into the trenches
operationally and on the econ level at
winelibrary.com and Wine Library a lot
of fun really got to speak with a bunch
of key executives people that have been
with me for a decade really talking
about the future obviously it's such a
different dynamic cuz I'm not their
day-to-day anymore and so it's
interesting the the relationship I have
with them because they're my homies they
were there with me but I'm not there
every day to reinforce with mine create
that consistent narrative that I am for
vaynermedia for example where I'm
operating but it's amazing to see the
trust and the relationship really
enjoyed having some of the vaynermedia
people at Wine Library bringing their
expertise --is to the conversation just
very excited about the family wine
business for the next decade a lot of
fun to interact spend a lot of time
talking to finance admission and those
kind of things
spoke to Brian dilatory and Jeff the ROS
operationally for both wine library the
store in winelibrary.com spending time
with Brandon John Kay and Brian Rudy
from development Brandon who runs the
kind of the show along with my dad so
just an incredible day fun to like slep
to Newark Airport Jersey Airport that I
used for my entire life until I moved to
Manhattan and so just a good solid meaty
day I think that up d-roc and I found
our cadence in episode 9 about really
pushing the envelope to bring more
access from the meetings really spending
an extra day or two editing getting
approvals
seeing the reaction from all of you on
episode 9 got us fired up and I think
you know given that it was Wine Library
we're on the client and the person of
the show I people be able to bring a lot
more meat in this episode of hope you
edited it proper d-roc and I just love
all of you guys so much thank you so
much for supporting dailyvee get getting
getting to go to Jersey for one of our
biggest oldest clients there's a lot of
fun new project we're working on can't
go a whole lot into it but what I can
say is that when you line when you align
yourself with very smart executives from
the client side there's nothing more
powerful I haven't you know I was blown
away
I've been interacted with the my
contemporary my partner on the other
side on this brand before and she was
just so massively impressive it just you
know when you align on religion you can
go fast and speed is such a bigger
aspect of business than people realize
and so instead of jockeying and
politicking and pondering and posturing
and debating for three to four months
we're just a do mode now now when you're
in do mode you [ __ ] get [ __ ] done
like that yeah the do mode when you do
good you get [ __ ] done something yes I I
think I'm gonna lose your mind in my
mind premier check by the TSA checkpoint
three okay thank you
what's that okay then I know you're
gonna leave that you see you know me so
well already just leave real [ __ ] d-roc
I think I should give you the mic good
episode right oh yeah we're just
figuring it out
so get
see